You may not like it, but can I
listen to it again?
That screen About the
injury I
'm confident that I won't hate it even if I hear it's
okay.  I got a log on top of it, and my
face was crushed
Why did I fall off
the cliff?
[Music]
I made a bigger mistake,
so I couldn't save people.
4 a
But it was a big wound for the
child.It was very sick.I was
too embarrassed to show
it to people.I thought I had done something terrible.
Shall I give it to you
[music]
It was windy that day
There was a river in that place
[music]
He had a
flower blooming in the evening
2 minutes
Sasaki-colored flower
Inside he had it
It's called a day when you should burn that flower
[music]